[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
28 août dernier dans l'est de montréal
une foule nombreuse participent à un
rassemblement baptisé professionnelle en
marche parmi les organisateurs de cet
événement le collectif reinfo qu'ovide
québec quand je vous invite et peut-être
à fermer les yeux tellement de ce
constat comme tout le monde l'a vue
d'utilisation de la pouvoir de tous est
alarmiste 2 qui
s'ingénient à générer de lapin lancé en
juin dernier le collectif reinfo covit
québec tente de se tailler une place
importante au sein du mouvement de
contestation des mesures sanitaires
une conférence de presse le 3 novembre
dernier nous en a révélé davantage sur
cette initiative qui suscite de plus en
plus de questions
nicolas était présent cette conférence
de presse du 3 novembre dernier ce qu'on
se demande tout d'abord c'est comment
ils se présentent eux dans ce genre
d'événement la public il se présente
seulement comme un collectif donc de
travers la santé de citoyens qui milite
pour une politique sanitaire plus juste
et proportionnée selon leur parole est
important de noter que dans la
conférence de pression mentionné que les
personnes présentes les professionnels
présents parler à leurs propres n'ont
donc pas au nom du collectif mais c'est
plutôt une espèce de plateforme qui
offre à des personnes qu'ils sentent que
leur point de vue n'est pas entendu dans
les médias traditionnels que leurs
points de vue peuvent peut-être à contre
courant du narratif officielle en guinée
comme ils disent et ils leur permettent
de s'exprimer jusque là tout va bien le
jeu et c'est tout à fait légitime comme
démarche et comme affirmation mais tout
à fait depuis justement dans la
conférence de presse ont dénoncé
notamment le passeport sanitaire le
maintien de l'état d'urgence et aussi la
vaccination des enfants encore une fois
jusque là tout le tout soit bien mais il
ya des informations quand même que quand
été propagée sur les vaccins et
conférence de presse le neuro chirurgie
alain rouleau qui mentionnait que les
personnes vaccinées peuvent être aussi
contagieuse attrapé autant l'aco vide
que les personnes non vaccinées
polluants autant pour lui ce serait un
argument contre le parti par vaccinale
c'est locustes pas tout à fait vrai
parce que même si on regarde les
chiffres 17 novembre au québec 8500 44
cas chez les non vaccinés et 4732 coop
chez les personnes vaccinées à dos dans
les 28 derniers jours ce que ça nous
indique ce bain c'est qu'il ya 4,8 fois
plus de chances d'attraper la coved si
on n'est pas vaccinée si on a juste pour
la proportion des gens la population qui
on parle de soi aussi la contagiosité le
c'est vrai que les personnes vaccinées
sont aussi contagieuse que les personnes
non vaccinées au pic de l'infection avec
les variants des tops donc si un cas
assez spécifique dans les premiers dans
les première instance dans l'infection
oui les personnes vaccinées soit autant
contagieuse mais cette contagiosité la
baisse assez rapidement que selon une
étude récente du dentiste donc à des
nuances apportées et lavagnac s'est
présenté à la conférence de presse ont
l'impression des vaccins servent à rien
finalement c'est l'impression générale
qui se dégage de cette conférence de
presse où il ya eu effectivement des
affirmations tout à fait légitime des
demi-vérités ça c'est une chose mais
parlons de la présence numérique de
reinfo qu'ovide et leur site web c'est
là où ça change ou le discours est quand
même différent exactement j'en ai parlé
un peu avec stéphanie y est professeur
en communication sociale à l'uqam qui
elle mène présentement une étude sur les
discours de groupes militants sur des
enjeux controversé et comment ces
discours le change dans l'espace
médiatique traditionnelle et dans
l'espace en ligne le fait d'avoir une
coalition ça permet justement de clamer
cette légitimité représentative de dire
au juste quelques individus isolés ya
les médecins il ya plusieurs médecins il
ya plusieurs personnes qui vient du spot
les différents groupes et là ils vont se
coaliser autour d'un dénominateur commun
qui est assez minimales et c'est ce
dénominateur commun le plus bas qui va
rallier tout le monde mais dans ce
collectif
il va y avoir des éléments plus polarisé
ans ou plus extrémistes la thèse de sa
recherche c'est que ce discours là est
modulé sur la plateforme donc c'est gros
plus on se permet d'aller un peu plus
loin alliant des propos un peu plus
extrêmes sur le cac forme en ligne parce
que justement c'est des espaces où ils
sont plus entourés de leurs
sympathisants ou les discours seront
moins questionnés et comme sous l'ancien
axée sur le site web de ré faut crever
dont on trouve des fonds ces formations
qui vont
c'est loin là des choses qui ont déjà
démenti de nombreuses fois à l'émission
on parle notamment de masse toxiques de
dictature mondiale qui dictature
sanitaires mondiales d'injection létale
de génocide duo vaccin on parle de
gonfler le nombre de morts ou encore que
les vaccins arn modifie le génome donc
cesser toutes des choses qui ont déjà
été vérifiée lancé véronique dans ces
termes-là le mot pour mot ce jeu était
contre-vérifier de nombreux soit par des
médias de vérification et là ça va
beaucoup plus loin que simplement
questionner vu le passé par vaccinale le
médecin d'urgence sanitaire nous avons
tenté de joindre les deux principaux
porte-parole de reinfo qu'avec québec
ainsi que les cinq personnes ayant pris
la parole lors de la conférence de
presse du pronom vambre ni le porte
parole de reinfo crevettes québec ni
l'administrateur du groupe facebook du
collectif n'ont voulu nous parler et
permet des cinq participants devront
accepter nous accorder des entrevues la
pharmacienne annie fortin et le dentiste
frank ou becker tous deux ont rappelé
qu'il parlait en leur nom personnel sans
nécessairement endosser toutes les idées
présentées sur des plateformes du
collectif rien vukovic québec selon
stéphanie est par contre de telles
interventions individuelles peuvent
permettre une estimation de discours
plus extrêmes au sein du collectif et un
mécanisme de légitimation qui se fait
alors c'est pas je pense que c'est
conscient je pense pas qu'on peut se
dire ah je ne savais pas qu'en faisant
partie de cette coalition le j'étais en
train de digitimes et les acteurs
quiconque qui comprennent qu'ils
prennent part également
je pense que ce serait naïf de penser ça
une coalition c'est justement solide et
c'est la force du nombre c'est la
représentativité qu'on veut mettre de
l'avant et je voudrais juste à éviter
les gens qui voudraient plus
d'informations sur info que vides ou
encore sur les affirmations qui ont été
faites à leur conférence de presse de
visiter notre site web on a publié deux
articles sur le sujet
le collectif reinfo qu'ovide québec ne
sort pas de nulle part ses racines sont
en fait en france là où le tout premier
collectif reinfo qu'ovide a vu le jour
en octobre 2020 louis foucher
controversé anesthésiste de la région de
marseille est le fondateur et maître à
penser de ce mouvement quelques mois à
peine il s'est érigé en figure de proue
déco vidéo sceptiques et des opposants
mesures sanitaires promulguée par le
gouvernement macron
rejoints par d'autres médecins et
experts dissident lui foucher a aussi
accueilli à bras ouverts dans son
collectif une foule bigarrée de
sympathisants des adeptes de médecine
alternative de mouvements spirituels en
tout genre et même des citoyens abonnés
à la pensée complotistes de cul à nantes
on retrouve désormais des antennes de
reinfo qu'ovide aux quatre coins de la
france est aussi dans une vingtaine de
villes réparties dans une douzaine de
pays
pour vous comprendrez fo kobe de france
là où tout a commencé on voulait
absolument s'entretenir avec william
audureau journaliste au quotidien le
monde auteur d'un livre récemment publié
intitulé dans la tête des complotistes
c'est véritablement lui qui a le plus
enquêter en france sur cette antenne de
reinfo qu'ovide bonjour william audureau
vu d'ici rien faut crever de france
paraît comme étant un mouvement assez
hétéroclite était pas très homogène
c'est bien ça nous c'est un mouvement
qui est
effectivement alors de prime abord c'est
un mouvement qui paraît très prudent
hier soir m'enferme plus touchées
emploie énormément et qui nous atteint
manière revendiquer des valeurs sont
très positives
dans la mesure où il estime qu' il ne
faut pas prendre de décisions hâtives on
a envie de dire oui il a raison si on
prend notre temps qu'on a c'est d'être
patient d'avoir de la prudence et de
regarder le réel souvent on n'est ni
pour ni contre mais la manière dont il
faudrait un truc le vide c'est-à-dire de
manière très organique finalement la
plupart des personnes peuvent prendre un
petit peu la propre initiative
on se retrouve assez facilement avec des
personnes qui n'ont absolument aucun
break bhagwan benkahla mais qui vont
essayer de promouvoir certains discours
parfois assez exotique on est dans
quelque chose d'assez spirituel parfois
d'assez d'ésotérique même il ya toutes
les espèces de gradation qui commence
par un discours se présente comme
scientifique et qui évolue vers des
imaginaires qui relève parfois au delà
de la religion d'état et qui relève
parfois de la désinformation d'ailleurs
dans quelle mesure et fo qu'invite
france est un vecteur de désinformation
alors déjà l'info que le vise c'est
quand même un collectif qui
insistent sur le fait qu'ils ne sont pas
anti vaccins en tenue anti masque mais
qui concentrent quasiment la totalité de
leur production sur la dangerosité
supposée des vaccins et la dangerosité
supposée des masques on peut bien sûr
surveiller dangerosité des vaccins c'est
normal
le problème c'est que reinfo qu'ovide en
général et les personnes qui écrit pour
info que vie dont un petit peu tendance
à arranger des chiffres de manière à
démontrer ce qu'ils ont envie de
démontrer et là dessus sont extrêmement
forts donc il arrive avec cette posture
par et scientifique qui paraît très
rationnel très prudente avec des
conclusions qui elles sont extrêmement
fortes qui consiste à dire attention le
vaccin c'est quand même dangereux et
évidemment de matériel que la sphère
anti vaccins repro volonté et avec la
diversité d'opinion qu'on retrouve au
sein de ce mouvement comment louis
foucher se positionne face aux
affirmations les plus extrêmes de
certaines ses sympathisants lui coucher
de manière générale il excelle à ne pas
dire non à ne pas exclure des hypothèses
même les plus extravagantes et quand il
est interrogé sur des rumeurs
vienne très clairement des frères k naan
il va avoir tendance à dit je me
prononce pas peut-être que ça existe moi
je ne sais pas donc c'est une manière
aussi pour lui de ne pas se couper d'une
part de la population qui est soutien
c'est une manière aussi de donner du
crédit à cette hypothèse là
et là dessus il est toujours un peu
difficile à cerner ce qui est capable
d'avoir un discours à la fois très posé
en apparence très mesurée et de l'autre
il s'acoquine très facilement de pèse
parfois très extrême william audureau
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien merci
avec son ami